[Music]
yeah one hour ago i go outside
we decided with my mother go to the
house take some dish chest stuff from
home and go back to the shelter and
while we were on the street near in my
house
near my house rocket
boom from rocket
roy house and was many fire and
a couple min thirty minutes ago my
head's uh
handshake and legs shaking
i when i feel terrible i always
call to my friends to feel my emotion
tell my emotions and after that i hear
support
and
feel after that call
you know and now when i tell you i feel
that i can
share about my experience i know that
you can't feel that like me but it's
real happen it's it's everything is real
take me through the moment when you've
realized there was war
now i'm in tunisia it's my hometown
native city where my parents live
one day i wake up and decided i wanted
to go to my parents i wanna some chill
relax i don't have work
in that days and i go
on 22nd february on the next day my mom
come to my room and said that lara do
you know that one bomb damaged house in
bravery probably it's a village near
kiev
and i was shocked
really i again i can't believe in that
after that i think
it's okay only one boom
maybe
i i can't believe that bar really can
happen
and then in this day we sleep in my in
our house
and i said to my father that i wanna i
wanna leave my
house journey i want to give and from
kiev move
uh to europe to poland to live i don't
know to slovakia czech republic but my
father said that um valerian stop you
see what the situation in the world
you can move on monday not today it was
friday i said okay
okay
and uh after that
uh many bombs uh these are destroyed
buildings in my house because um my
native city close to belarussia and la
russia
and
just right here we are sitting here
in shelter
but we're here for part time but time we
can go to the supermarket by
some food or go to the house take some
stuff
but part time most of time of the day
we're here of course because it's the
most safe place because another people
live in a subway
and
i have a more better
shelter than them
and i know that and i said everyday
sense to my family that i live in that
building i have a
nice shelter as you see i have shower
toilet fridge i have [ __ ] dog
food
uh i go to the today
wake up my father said hmm
let's again watch news we watch news for
24 hours a day
uh he might quote him after that i go to
the shower
and
said and always ask like can we go
outside can we go outside and he always
said no no then you're dangerous but for
me it's so hard you know i didn't live
with my
parents for five
years maybe when i go
i go to kiev whenever 16
and
i'm feeling myself now like i'm again 16
2 i'm a little child i can't work i
can't travel i can't meet with my
friends chilling street simple i can't
i can't turn
nothing nothing
i'm tired of everything not like from my
parents everything what happened i won
as it did end how often have you left
the bomb shelter in the last four days
do you or are you there always only on
little times only two times what why did
you leave the bomb shelter
uh because i wanna see beautiful sky and
my dog need to do some
things on the street
come on come on you come into the shop
come say hi hello there's a dog
in the supermarket if you wanted to go
inside you need to stay in a line
for i don't know for maybe for one hour
i a couple of days ago i wanted to buy
bread i stayed in the line for one hour
and when i wanted to get bread a woman
said said me sorry brett and please wait
for 40 minutes i said okay
my go away
can we talk now just about the situation
in your hometown
in the city
also
i'm already said that many things
so everyday soldiers
this other skills killed
simple people they really
i read that
russian soldiers live in houses in
near my city
russian rockets
destroy
the houses where live people one russian
bomb
destroyed cinema which survived in the
second world war
in this cinema
i
spent my childhood i visited with my
classmates um really today the most
dangerous day i think from these seven
days
uh just because uh now i feel that var
starts this is the first day of seventh
day when i feel that it's really
really dangerous situation not in
ukraine in really in the world
i'm 20 years old i live in a world where
we have elon musk
uh electricity electric cars i really
can't believe
like it's second world war
how are your mom and dad
my father terrible mother terrible of
the situation too of course everybody
who everyone wants that
it to end
their so my mother is so scared she
don't know what what to do but
again we want to say thanks to our
father
that
try to
help us feel safe
what are you doing to keep yourself
entertained i'm trying to
make tick tocks you know it's a really
nice
like
i'm
i'm
uh to feel myself more positive i'm
everyday think that tomorrow everything
will end
uh i'm always communicate with my
parents my parents have a nice sense of
humor and of course
i make
tick-tock and just why i'm feeling
like
that i do something i noticed it i'm
really do something i have a i have
people who always write me i
help to our ukrainian army and donate
money people who find me from tiptop
donate money to ukrainian army so i feel
that i help to my country i'm i'm proud
that i'm ukrainian i'm proud that i live
here and i'm proud that i'm staying now
in this bomb shelter how do you feel
about the russian people they need to do
something they need to go to the red
square and say that
maybe you know this is a very popular
phrase
in our countries that putin hui law
you know what does it mean no
it's like a putting
or putting okay something like that
yeah and after that they can maybe
change something if they sit and do
nothing they will be like in a box many
people in that country can't understand
what really happened in ukraine many
people from russian don't believe that
people that that
woman in subway you can burn a child
it's a real situation
does it make you feel worried about what
life will be like
um
i'm i i said you again i'm i'm scared
now but my i believe that in the future
everything will be okay because i know
that ukraine
uh
wiener what do you want to say to the
people of
the world that are less watching this
video
oh
i have many words to say i think that
everybody need to say thanks that he can
live
this life without war
you need really
when you see the sky you need to say
thank you when you see the sun you need
to send you simple life when you simple
sit
in a
you know in your flesh
you need to really god bless that has
happened
because yurika we
we need to always be helpful to each
other say thanks to each other and to
the world too
and
to
peace love
to everybody i think
[Music]
right now we are sitting in a bunker
like a bomb shelter in one of the uh one
of the buildings when you wake up uh and
you see
all the messages about like that russia
started the war with ukraine and the
troops are coming and the explosions
were in the morning